squad leader said darzee on bei would be  my last mission easy in easy out and  afterwards my iron bear class mech would  be all mine  routine gig he said  [Music]  it was a deathtrap we never stood a  chance  [Music]  the rest of my squad was wiped out but  iron bear kept me alive  [Music]  now he's all I've got  we look out for each other his equipment  comes in handy even off the battlefield  [Music]  parts aren't cheap but I keep them tuned  and ready to fight  [Music]  [Applause]  not having a squad it takes some getting  used to at least iron bears sentry mode  lets me catch up on sleep  [Music]  tons of walking tritanium  [Music]  ffs of BFG you  [Music]  you  [Music]  you